[Musik]
mit einem brutto in landsprodukt von
fast 24 Billionen Dollars in die
Vereinigten Staaten die mit Abstand
größte Volkswirtschaft der Welt die
US-Wirtschaft ist so groß dass sie
allein fast ein Viertel des weltweiten
BP erwirtschaftet die Amerikaner
konsumieren mehr Produkte als jedes
andere Land fast jedes Land will mit
ihnen handelt treiben es ist der mit
Abstand wichtigste und lukrativste Markt
der Welt niemand absolut niemand kommt
an die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit dieser Supermacht
heran aber wie offen ist ankel Sam
wirklich für den Welthandel man könnte
ja meinen die USA seinen global ganz
dicke vertreten und preschten in
gewohnter Weise voran bei allem was mit
Freihandel und Handelserleichterungen zu
tun hat aber dem ist in Wirklichkeit
nicht so die USA sind ein weniger
Freihandelsabkommen beteiligt als z.B
die Ukraine noch nicht mal mit
Südamerika gibt es eine Partnerschaft
obwohl man doch quasi Nachbar ist aber
gerade das Verhältnis zu lateinamer
Amerika ist für die us-handelspolitik
ein absolut wunderpunkt es ist die
Geschichte einer verpassten Chance und
einer Demütigung für Amerika am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
worin diese verpasste Chance und die
Demütigung für Amerika besteht doch
vielleicht könnte bald alles ganz anders
aussehen und wenn die Sterne besonders
gut stehen könnte es gar ein Happy End
geben und dieses Happy End könnte dann
wahrlich globale Auswirkungen haben na
seid ihr gespannt wovon ich hier rede
dann würde ich euch gerne bevor wir dazu
kommen wie das alles mit dem freien
Welthandel begann noch einen heißen Tipp
für den Fall geben dass ihr euer
Englisch auf ein perfektes Level bringen
möchtet denn was ist schließlich in der
globalen Wirtschaft heute wichtiger als
gutes Englisch einwandfreie
Kommunikation und ein guter erster
Eindruck und was ist die Königsdisziplin
beim Erlernen einer Fremdsprache genau
die perfekte Aussprache tja und jetzt
haltet euch fest es gibt nämlich einen
sehr innovativen und für jeden
zugänglichen Weg diese so leicht zu
erlernen wie nie zuvor und zwar mit der
genialen englishlern App unseres
Sponsors Elsa das Besondere an ihr sie
analysiert die Fehler in deiner
Aussprache durch modernste kialgorithmen
so vergleicht sie deine Aussprache mit
der eines Muttersprachlers bewertet
deinen Redefluss und deine Betonung zeig
dir alle deine Fehler und erstellt auf
Grundlage dessen dann ein auf dich
individuell abgestimmtes stufenweises
Trainingsprogramm für jeden einzelnen
laut schauen wir uns doch mal an wie das
ganze funktioniert vielleicht wird mein
Englisch mit Else ja so toll dass ich
irgendwann auch auf dem englischen
visualpolitikkanal einspringen kann ja
genau als hätte ich noch nicht genug zu
tun also ich habe schon den
Einstufungstest hinter mir und was
empfiehlt mir Elsa also irgendwie LR und
W ja damit das weiß ich das ist so meine
Schwachstelle gucken wir mal was der mir
jetzt hier anbietet wie ich das ganze
verbessern kann also da kommen erstmal
Videos da wird das Ganze erklärt aber
die will ich jetzt auch gar nicht
sondern ich will gleich in die Übung
einsteigen so das ist das hier ist Übung
easy erstmal easy ganz easy ich spreche
das jetzt mal wusst falsch aus
wie ja darf man nicht so aussprechen s s
so son ich habe wie wie gesagt das ist
so ein typische deutsche Aussprache W
aha si ihr da okay was kommt als
nächstes what ich spreche mal wieder
falsch aus what ja
what bitte geht doch
wenn ja ist halt falsch ne und ich kann
jetzt auf den Fehler drauf gehen und
hier steht eine Erklärung was genau ich
machen soll um den laut richtig
auszusprechen ich kann mir das sogar
vorlesen
lassen ja es ist halt kein W sondern ein
W also probieren wir es mal richtig
auszusprechen
W sehr gut tja mit diesem auf deine
tatsächlichen Schwachstellen
fokussierten Trainingsprogramm kannst du
nicht nur deine Sprechweise und
Intonation gezielt korrigieren sonder
nebenbei auch viele weitere vokabelen
phras und Sätze für die tägliche
Kommunikation lernen damit kannst du
deine Englischkenntnisse so schnell
effizient und vor allem unterhaltsam
perfektionieren wie nie zuvor Elsa
bietet über 1600 Lektionen und 40 Themen
von Business English über
Bewerbungsgespräche bis zum Flirt und
reisevokabular und Alsan Häubchen auch
noch vielfältige Community Funktionen
möchtest du z.B außer von der KI auch
von Real menenschen aus der ganzen Welt
lernen oder zusammen mit deinen Kumpels
und Kollegen bei einem sprechwettbewerb
antreten das alles und noch viel mehr
bietet Elsa in einem wirklich toll
angebott denn natürlich gibt es für
visualpolitik Zuschauer wieder eine ganz
besondere Aktion in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video findet ihr zwei Links
mit dem ersten kannst du Elsa kostenlos
herunterladen und die Pro Version für 7
Tage testen mit dem zweiten gelangst du
zu wirklich fantastischen
Rabattangeboten die von 40% für das
Jahresabo bis zu 55% auf die lebenslange
Mitgliedschaft reichen also zögere nicht
tu dir was Gutes und bring dein Englisch
endlich auf ein geschliffenes Level denn
in der heutigen vernetzten Welt hat
perfekte Aussprache noch nie geschadet
so und nun lass uns einen schnellen
Blick in die Geschichte werfen um zu
erfahren wie das alles begann mit dem
freien Welthandel auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geht's Handel ist so alt wie die
Menschheit selbst denn jeder Tausch von
Gütern ist Handel aber das was wir
heutzutage im Sinn haben wenn wir von
Handel reden das ist das uns bekannte
internationale Handelsnetz das sind die
Abkommen vieler Staaten untereinander
das sind die Produktionsketten und die
Handelswege aber all das ist eine sehr
junge Entwicklung diese große Vernetzung
der Weltwirtschaft gibt es erst seit ein
paar Jahrzehnten die ersten Anfänger von
so etwas wie internationalen Freihandel
gehen auf das Jahr 1860 zurück die
treibende Kraft damals war wenig
überraschend das britische Empire dieses
unterzeichnete im Januar 1860 den
Vertrag von Kopten Chevalier mit
Frankreich und ohne jetzt groß ins
Detail zu gehen man senkte zwischen
beiden Ländern die Zölle und schaffte
sie teilweise ganz ab das ermöglichte
freien Warenaustausch das zweite für die
handelsgeschichte bedeutende Dokument
war der Wesser Vertrag von 1919 und
warum nun weil dieser den Handel
zwischen Staaten als einen
entscheidenden Faktor für den globalen
Wohlstand ansah und wie äußerte sich das
konkret in diesem sehr umstrittenen
Vertrag nun ganz einfach er verbot den
deutschen Handelsbeschränkungen bzw
bestimmte Zölle im Handel mit anderen am
Vertrag beteiligten Staaten es handelte
sich also quasi um Freihandel als Strafe
tja denn noch gab es im Laufe des 20
Jahrhunderts erst einmal einen Haufen
Rückschläge für den freien
internationalen Handel der Zweite
Weltkrieg und der kalte Krieg wirkten
hier wie riesige Bremsklötze allerdings
nicht überall die USA fördert in ihrem
Machtbereich natürlich den Handel um
ihren Block wirtschaftlich stark zu
machen praktisch alle Staaten des
Westens profitierten davon aber zugleich
agierten die Amerikaner mit knallharten
Protektionismus in strategisch wichtigen
Wirtschaftszweigen also Hightech
beispielsweise international
konzentrierte man sich hauptsächlich auf
Sicherheitsfragen das änderte sich erst
wieder in den 1990er Jahren mit dem Ende
des Kalten Krieges da begann die fast
Explosion artige Ausweitung des
Welthandels auf das Niveau das wir heute
kennen aber wisst ihr was das
Überraschendste dabei ist dieser Prozess
wurde federführend nicht von den USA
angeführt und das hat viel mit der
geostrategischen Lage der USA zu tun
hört jetzt gut
[Musik]
zu von der Isolation zur
Konfrontation es gibt eine fast
einhellige Meinung über das Geheimnis
des Erfolgs der USA das Land verfügt
über die beste Lage in geopolitischer
Hinsicht diesen Konsens gibt es schon
lange schaut euch an da die Vereinigten
Staaten im Ausland keinen Feind finden
der sie erst bedrohen könnte ist das
amerikanische Volk stets damit
beschäftigt seine Situation im Lande zu
verbessern Alexi tov die Demokratie in
Amerika
1835 bis
1840 die besondere Sicherheit der
amerikanischen Geografie gab den
Vereinigten Staaten eine wirtschaftliche
Sicherheit die es ihn ermöglichte sich
auf die Künste des Friedens zu
konzentrieren während sie anderen
Nationen die Möglichkeit gaben ihrer
Lust am Krieg zu fröhnen David Potter
Menschen des Überflusses
wirtschaftlicher Überfluss und der
amerikanische Charakter
1954 man kann es auch einfacher
ausdrücken die USA sind umgeben von
Freunden oder von Wasser sie mussten nie
eine Invasion fürchten und sie konnten
sich ganz in Ruhe auf ihre Wirtschaft
konzentrieren das war früher so und ist
auch heute noch so die USA konnten
wachsen ohne dass ein Krieg auf ihrem
Territorium sie jemals bedroht hätte und
das gibt Invest und Unternehmen nun mal
langfristig Planungssicherheit okay ich
weiß es gab mal den Bürgerkrieg Nord
gegen Süd und auch de sch Mützel mit
Mexiko im 19 Jahrhundert aber das ist
wirklich schon lange her und vor allem
ist das Kleinkram im Verhältnis zu den
Kriegen die in Europa Afrika und Asien
tobten und die Wirtschaft und den Handel
immer wieder zurückwarfen es gab auch
nie einen tyran in den USA der seine
Landsleute knechtete und sich selbst die
Taschen vollstopfte anstatt sich um den
Wohlstand des Landes zu kümmern man kann
wohl sagen dass amerikanische
Präsidenten kaum etwas so sehr fürchten
wie eine Sch Wirtschaft denn dann werden
sie nämlich ratsfs abgewählt wir haben
es hier also mit hervorragenden
Bedingungen zu
[Musik]
tun von der geografischen Lage bis hin
zum politischen System all diese
Vorteile konnte Amerika zum ökonomischen
Vorteil nutzen sie konnten jahrelang
ihre Wirtschaft ausbauen und einen
riesigen florierenden Binnenmarkt
erschaffen und dieser Binnenmarkt war
geschützt vor der Welt außerhalb der USA
es war fast egal was dort passierte die
Amerikaner erkannten schnell was sie da
geschaffen hatten und sie taten alles um
Ihren Schatz zu schützen man wollte
nicht dass die Welt dazu kam und störte
mit den Problemen auf dem alten
Kontinent wollte man sich nicht befassen
es ist eine regelrechte politische
Denkschule aus dieser Haltung entstanden
man nennt sie den amerikanischen
Isolationismus hier ein konkretes
Beispiel dafür wie sich das auf die
internationale Politik auswirkte die
Vereinigten Staaten wollten nach dem
Ersten Weltkrieg partout nicht dem
Völkerbund den Vorläufer der UNO
beitreten obwohl ihr eigener Präsident
buo Wilson einer der größten Befürworter
man kann fast sagen dessen Gründer war
tja sowas ist aus heutiger Perspektive
kaum vorstellbar wodochch heutzutage
fast nichts auf der Welt ohne die USA
geht aber damals waren die Amerikaner
nicht sonderlich am Rest der Welt
interessiert egal was ihr Präsident
wollte aber das alles änderte sich mit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg oder besser gesagt
an dem Tag als die Japaner Paul harber
bombardierten an diesem Tag änderte sich
die Perspektive der USA schlagartig und
für immer von diesem Moment an schaute
das Land nie wieder weg wenn irgendwo in
der Welt Probleme auftauchten nach dem
Schock von Pearl harber Griff Amerika
also in den Zweiten Weltkrieg ein streng
genommen führte es zwei Kriege
gleichzeitig einen in Europa gegen
Hitler und den anderen im Pazifik gegen
die Japaner und von da an blieben sowohl
der Pazifik als auch Europa im Fokus der
Amerikaner sie sind dort heute noch
präsent und engagieren sich
wirtschaftlich und sichheitpolitisch in
diesen Regionen ich meine nicht übel für
ein Land das kurz zuvor von der übrigen
Welt nichts wissen wollte und sich
lieber isolierte okay Pearl Harbor war
ein außerordentlich spektakuläres
Ereignis die ganze Welt kennt die Bilder
von den brennenden Kriegsschiffen die
schwer getroffen und versinkend im Hafen
liegen viel unauffälliger weil auch
weniger bildgewaltig ist aber ein
anderes Ereignis
jenerzeit im August 1941 wurde die
atlantikkarter vereinbart diese geht auf
ein geheimes Treffen zwischen den
britischen Premier Churchill und seinem
amerikanischen Amtskollegen rooswell
zurück beide Länder legten darin
folgendes Ziel fest Klausel 4 allen
Staaten ob klein oder groß ob siegreich
oder besiegt die Möglichkeit des
gleichen Zugangs zum Welthandel und zu
den für ih wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand
notwendigen Rohstoffen zu gewähren aus
der atlantikkarta vom 14 August 1941
Amerika entwickelte einen fast
zwanghaften Drang Pakte und Bündnisse zu
schließen wirtschaftlich aber auch
militärisch man kann sowohl den
marshalpl als auch die NATO in diese
Politik einordnen es ist nur logisch
dass die Vereinigten Staaten alles in
ihrer Macht stehende tun sollten um zur
Rückkehr zu einer normalen
wirtschaftlichen Gesundung in der Welt
weitzutragen ohne die es keine
politische Stabilität und keinen
sicheren Frieden geben kann Regierungen
politische Parteien oder Gruppen die
versuchen menschliches Elend für den
Zweck politischer oder sonstiger
Vorteile aufrecht zu erhalten werden auf
den Widerstand der Vereinigten Staaten
stoßen Rede des Außenministers George
Marshall am 5 juni 1947 die Priorität
war damals nach dem Sieg über Hitler
Deutschland ganz klar alle
wirtschaftlichen und handelspolitischen
Instrumente wurden in die Schlacht gegen
den nächsten Tyrann geworfen gegen die
Sowjetunion die Amis waren schier
besessen davon Vereinbarung zu treffen
die Ihnen einen geopolit Vorteil
gegenüber den Russen verschaffen würden
mit anderen Worten der Handel wurde zu
einer Ressource mit der man kämpfen
konnte es ging weniger um den Handel
selbst er war ein Mittel in der
eindämmungsstrategie der Amerikaner
gegen die Sowjets und jetzt fragt ihr
euch sicher war denn diese
zweckentfrendung schlimm nein denn sie
brachte sogar große Fortschritte im
internationalen
Handel im Jahr 1947 fanden in Genf
mehrere multilaterale Treffen statt um
am Ende das allgemeine Zoll und
Handelsabkommen gat zu beschließen gat
steht für general agreement of tariffs
and trade es handelte sich um eine
Vereinbarung unter 23 Staaten um Zölle
und Handelshemmnisse abzubauen und auf
dem damaligen Gipfel in Genf fanden die
hitzigsten Debatten zwischen zwei
Ländern statt die sonst immer auf ihre
besondere Freundschaft verweisen nämlich
zwischen den USA und Großbritannien
damals vertraute England als die alte
macht nicht auf eine schnelle Öffnung
der
Märkte die Amis aber drückten jetzt als
neue Führungsmacht der Welt aufs Tempo
bei den Reformen und beim Abbau von
handelshemmenisen man wollte niedrige
Zölle gemeinsame Regeln völlige Freiheit
beim barenaustausch das Ziel der
Amerikaner war es vor allem Westeuropa
wirtschaftlich und auch militärisch als
Bollwerk gegen die Sowjets aufzubauen
heute wissen wir dass sie sehr gut
gelungen ist aber damals war sehr
schwierig diese Dinge zu verwirklichen
denn in den 50er Jahren war das
Misstrauen in die neue bipolare
Weltordnung einfach nch zu groß die
Britten z.B hatten Riesenangst vor einen
Wiedererstarken Deutschlands das
gatabkommen wurde zwar verabschiedet
aber es hat die Westmächte nicht dazu
gezwungen ihre Zölle zu senken das blieb
im Ermessen der einzelnen
[Musik]
Regierungen und damals gab es noch einen
weiteren Versuch Handel zu erleichtern
und Zölle abzubauen nämlich die havan
Karta aus dem Jahr 1947 45 Länder waren
daran beteiligt und verhandelten bis
1950 über den Abbau von Zoll tja und wer
war der Showstopper hier na die USA oder
besser gesagt das isolationistische
Gesicht an Sams 1950 kündigte Präsident
Truman an dass er die Havana Karta dem
US-Kongress nicht zur Ratifizierung
vorlegen würde der Grund die Mehrheit
der Abgeordneten war sowieso gegen einen
Beitritt zu dieser Organisation und
damals galt folgendes wenn die
Vereinigten Staaten nicht mitmachten
passierte rein gar nichts die havan
kartter verlief im Sande und damit
platzte auch der Traum von einer
internationalen Handelsorganisation eine
solche zu schaffen war nämlich das Ziel
der havanakartter gewesen aber immerhin
hatte man mit dem gat zumindest etwas in
der Hand in dessen Rahmen wurde dann in
den folgenden Jahr hinten immer wieder
verhandelt oder besser gesagt sich
durchgewurstelt denn die gatregeln
deckten nur den Warenmarkt ab
Dienstleistungen geistiges Eigentum oder
Auslandsinvestitionen blieben außen vor
mit den gatverhandlungen erreichte man
immer nur minimalvereinbarungen die
viele Länder dann oft nicht einhielten
als es darauf ankam zwischen 1947 und
1990 fanden im Rahmen des gababkommens
insgesamt acht Verhandlungsrunden statt
das Problem war dass diese Verhandlungen
sehr lange dauerten im Schnitt 29 Monate
pro Runde ja ihr habt richtig gehört
jedes Mal wenn die Staaten einen Handel
hemnis abbauen wollten haben sie im
Durchschnitt mehr als zwei Jahre lang
miteinander verhandelt ein paar
Fortschritte wurden immerhin erzielt die
sogenannte Kennedy Runde ab 1964 war z.B
ein großer Schritt nach vorn weil die
Zölle auf viele Rohstoffe gesenkt wurden
bemerkenswert war auch die letzte große
Verhandlungsrunde ab 1986 die Uruguay
Runde sie dauerte 87 Monate also über 7
Jahre in dieser Zeit fiel die Berliner
Mauer und die Sowjetunion brach zusammen
tja aber 1993 kam dann die Einigung der
Kalte Krieg war ohnehin vorbei und die
neue Welt brauchte ein neues System der
handelskooperation und wie das aussah
schauen wir uns jetzt
an Clinton die WTO und Amerikas
zögern der 15 April 1994 war ein
historischer Tag für die Weltwirtschaft
ab diesem Tag unterzeichneten 123 Länder
darunter auch die USA das Abkommen von
Marrakesch mit dem die
Welthandelsorganisation WTO gründet
wurde das war der endgültige stadschuss
für die globale wirtschaftliche
Integration wie wir sie heute kennen wie
ihr seht kam von diesem Moment an immer
mehr Handelsabkommen hinzu es handelte
sich um einen wichtigen Meilenstein für
die WTO dass bald auch China beitrat und
sich der Markt des Riesenreiches öffnete
auch die Amerikaner waren zwar große
Unterstützer der WTO und des Freihandels
in der Welt aber und das ist das kuriose
sie selbst agierten äußerst zögerlich
wenn es darum ging selbst an einem
Freihandelsabkommen teilzunehmen zu
dieser Zeit war die einzige
Partnerschaft der USA ein Abkommen mit
Kanada aus dem Jahr 1988 1994 kam dann
noch Mexiko dazu und es entstand das
North American free trade agreement
NAFTA das war es dann aber auch schon
erst 2004 unterzeichneten die
Vereinigten Staaten neue
Freihandelsabkommen mit Chile Australien
janien Singapur der Dominik Republik und
Mittelamerika der damalige Präsident
George W bush war ein starker
Befürworter solcher Partnerschaften doch
im Jahr 2005 erhielt Amerika eine herbe
Abfuhr was war passiert nun hört gut
zu eine Supermacht bekommt einen
[Musik]
Korb im November 2003 trafen sich 34
Länder praktisch der gesamte
amerikanische Kontingent in Miami man
wollte einen vom weißen Haus
ausgearbeiteten Plan erörtern der darauf
abzielte das nordamerikanische
Freihandelsabkommen NAFTA auch auf
latetin Amerika auszudehnen damit wollte
man die amerikanische Freihandelszone
ftaa schaffen das Abkommen sollte
innerhalb von zwei Jahren abgeschlossen
werden aber 2005 auf dem vierten
Amerikagipfel in Argentinien sah sich
George W Bush mit einer roten Welle
konfrontiert gegen die er nicht ankam es
handelte sich um den sogenannten
Sozialismus des 21 jahrhunderts der
damals Süd Amerika überrollte dieseen
gibt es übrigens immer mal wieder auch
heute noch aber schaut euch mal dieses
Video
an
[Musik]
democraaja die war keinen Lateinamerikas
sondern ein Angebot Washingtons das
abgelehnt wurde es handelte sich um eine
kolossale Demütigung für die US
Außenpolitik die sozialistischen Führer
gaben Washington einen Korb vor allen
Augen der Welt unverrichtete Dinge
verließ bushch Argentinien und das Nein
zu den USA bedeutete auch dass
Südamerika eine einmalige Gelegenheit
ausschlug sich mit der größten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt zu verbinden
Bush konnte es kaum glauben schaut her
tja und den Amis ist daraufhin die Lust
auf weitere Abkommen vergangen macht
doch euren Dreck alleine so kann man den
Frust Amerikas wohl am besten
beschreiben aber trotzdem kam es zu
weiteren Abkommen als Führungsmacht muss
man eben oft eine Geduld aufbringen wie
Eltern sie haben müssen die gerade
Teenager erziehen also schauen wir uns
mal an wie es
[Musik]
weiterging der Kater nach der
lateinamerikanischen
Abfuhr derzeit sind nur folgende 19 US
Freihandelsabkommen in
Kraft wenn wir zusätzlich zu den
Freihandelsabkommen noch andere weniger
wichtige Abkommen hinzurechnen wirken
die USA fast ein wenig isoliert seht
euch an aber wie ist es möglich dass
Länder wie Peru die Türkei China oder
sogar die Ukraine mehr Handelsabkommen
unterzeichnet haben als die Vereinigten
Staaten was ist da los nun das eben
gezeigte Schaubild ist nur eine Seite
der
Medaille wenn die US OFA wickeln den
Großteil ihres Handels nach der
Meistbegünstigungsklausel ab das ist
eine WT Klausel die garantiert dass die
beste Behandlung die ein Mitgliedsland
einem anderen Mitglied gewährt für alle
gelten muss oder besser gesagt wenn ein
Land mit den USA zu niedrigen Zöllen
handelt gelten diese niedrigen Zölle für
alle das gilt quasi für den normalen
Handel der USA mit anderen Mitgliedern
der WTO außer man hat extra Abkommen
geschlossen die etwas anderes vorsehen
anhand dieser
Meistbegünstigungsklausel legen die
Vereinigten Staaten ihre Zölle fest und
wenden Sie dann pauschal an das FHT
z.bpiel dazu dass rund die Hälfte aller
US-Importe im Jahr 2021 zollfrei
eingeführt wurden bei rund 15% gab es
zollsenkung und bei rund 1% niedrige
Abgaben zu Gunsten ärmerer
Länder mit anderen wor es ist nicht so
dass sich die USA von der Welt
abgeschottet oder auf die Vorteile des
Handels verzichtet hätten sondern sie
haben die WTO Regeln für Zölle bis zum
Äußersten ausgereist aber gab es da
nicht einen regelrechten zollkrieg den
Trump gegen den Rest der Welt geführt
hat ja das ist richtig wenn alles normal
läuft haben die USA niedrige Zölle gemäß
WTO maisistbegünstigungsklausel im
Durchschnitt hat man einen niedrigen
Zolltarif von 3,5% ein der niedrigsten
der Welt allerdings nutzen die USA auch
die Möglichkeit die Höhe der Zölle für
jede Art von Produkt individuell aus
auszuhandeln und festzulegen dadurch hat
Washington viel mehr politische
Kontrolle über das
außenhandelsmanagement und genau das
erklärt Nachrichten wie diese juni 2022
die millionenschwere Krise der
spanischen schwarzen Olive wegen des
us-zolls 30 Oktober 2021 die EU und die
USA entschärfen ihren zollkrieg auf
Stahl und Aluminium im Prinzip ist es so
man kann mit den USA im Normalfall gute
Geschäfte machen zu niedrigen oder fast
gar kein Zöllen liegt man aber mit ankel
Sam m klinch können Sie auch ganz anders
sieehe Trump aber wie ihr wisst ist sein
Nachfolger beiden auch nicht gerade ein
weisenknabe vor allem gegenüber
China nun ist es aber auch nicht so dass
die Amerikaner sich seit der
Enttäuschung in Argentinien absolut
nicht um Freihandel bemüht hätten da gab
es Initiativen mit dem Nahen Osten oder
mit der Europäischen Union doch mit
Trump geriet das alles ins Stocken wobei
wir hier Trump nicht die alleinige
Schuld geben wollen vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass Deutschland sonst ohne
Probleme handelt treibt mit brutalen
Diktaturen die z tausende ihrer Bürger
Morden aber das ist ein anderes Thema
für ein eigenes Video kommen wir zurück
zu den USA und zu Lateinamerika denn da
tut sich gerade etwas denn manchmal gibt
es sie noch die Liebe auf den zweiten
Blick und was es damit auf sich hat
verrate ich euch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt zwei Kontinente versuchen es noch
mal
miteinander im Juni 2022 wurde die
Gründung der
allianceic in the Americas zunächst
angekündigt und Anfang 2023 wurde diese
Allianz dann Wirklichkeit es soll sich
dem Namen nach um eine Partnerschaft
handeln die Wirtschaftswachstum und
Wohlstand auf dem ganzen amerikanischen
Kontinent zum Ziel hat leider sind noch
nicht alle mit an Wort aber immerhin
Barbados Kanada Chile cololumbien Costa
Rica die Dominikanische Republik Ecuador
Mexiko Panama Peru und Uruguay das ganze
hat den Anschein einer zweiten
ftaa dieser Dialog bringt die Stärke den
Einfallsreichtum und die Vielfalt einer
unglaublich dynamischen Region zusammen
wir machen 90% des BP der westlichen
Hemisphäre aus fast zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung es gibt nichts was wir nicht
gemeinsam tun könnten Anthony Jay
blinken US Außenminister bisher sind nur
wenige Details bekannt was genau da ent
stehen soll aber das Weiße Haus hat
klargestellt dass diese Initiative
darauf abzielt den Handel die
Investitionen und die Anwendung
gemeinsamer Regeln zwischen den
Mitgliedstaaten zu fördern fakt ist dass
zahlreiche Skeptiker meinen das Abkommen
würde keinen großen Unterschied zum
Status Quo machen es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass die amerikanische
Partnerschaft für wirtschaftlichen
Wohlstand die Handelsströme zwischen den
USA und den teilnehmenen Ländern
wesentlich erhöhen wird da sich das
Forum kaum auf die Handelspolitik
konzentriert außerdem sind
Verpflichtungen zur Verbesserung des
Marktzugangs für US-Exporte und Importe
aus den teilnehmen Ländern nicht
Bestandteil der Verhandlungen im
Gegensatz zum indopacific economic
Framework haben die Vereinigten Staaten
mit allen bis auf einen Teilnehmer
Handelsabkommen geschlossen oder
verhandeln mit ihnen was einen Anstieg
des Handelsvolumens noch
unwahrscheinlicher macht aber vielleicht
über sehen sie ja dass die Partnerschaft
auf insgesamt vier politischen Säulen
fußt bei denen es um mehr geht als nur
um reines Handelsvolumen erstens
regionale wettbfähigkeit zweitens
Resilienz drittens Schaffung gemeinsamen
Wohlstands und viertens integrative und
nachhaltige Investitionen natürlich ist
sie auch ein Mittel mit den die
Regierung beiden den Einfluss Chinas
zurückdringen möchte und wie nun durch
die Förderung regionaler Produktions und
Lieferketten das nhoring worüber wir
hier auf visualpolitik schon oft
gesprochen haben kurz gesagt weg von den
weit entfernten Produktion stäten in
Asien oder gar in
China es könnte also eine zweite Chance
für Lateinamerika darstellen ein für
alle Mal einen großen Sprung nach vorne
zu machen es ist die Chance der Latinos
den größten Konsum und Investition Markt
der Welt zu nutzen und vielleicht ist es
auch für die USA eine Chance in Sachen
Welthandel und Freihandelsabkommen
wirkliche Führungsstärke zu zeigen aber
an diesem Punkt interessiert uns eure
Meinung denkt ihr dass die USA in ihrer
Handelspolitik viel ehrgeiziger sein
sollten wäre das eine gute oder eher
eine schlechte Sache und wie seht ihr
Europas Rolle in diesem Spiel wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like Teil mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es mit ihnen
vergesst bitte auch nicht auf meinem
neuen persönlichen Kanal vorbeizuschauen
den Link dazu findet ihr oben rechts
hinter dem iymbol natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit uns h dies Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung oder in dem Video
macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald